was würdet ihr machen wenn eure träume
komplett kontrollieren und einstellen
könnte was ihr wollt werdet ihr durch
new york fliegen für den weg alexander
kunden oder euren castor richtig zu
sagen dass eben unter meinem letztlich
hat sie mir sehr sehr häufig
vorgeschlagen ein video zur luziden
träumen zu machen beziehungsweise zum
klar träumt und gestern hat bei youtube
ein video vorgeschlagen dass ich den
titel trägt wie man in seinem schlaf
geträumt in drei minuten
das klingt vielversprechend dieses video
und ein video welches den titel prinz
sofort luzide träumen haben in den
ersten sekunden erst mal ein bild
gezeigt wird von jemanden der sein und
rasch so richtig hart sagt dass es im
markt
auf jeden fall werde ich die aussage
dieser beiden videos in dieser woche
überprüfen und luzide träume ist nichts
weiteres als in seinen träumen einmal
wirklich machen zu können was man will
zu kreieren was man will und sich danach
auch noch daran zu erinnern
deswegen auch geht's stell dir vor du
bist nachts allein auf dem nächsten
bahnhof du merkst dass der seit zwei
straßen bereits an man folgt und wirst
du immer schneller der mann wird
ebenfalls immer schneller bis er
letztendlich beide so schnell rentieren
können adrenalin da spielt dann im blut
war dein ganzes leben zieht an den
verband mit allen dingen wie du bereits
erlebt hast und um auch gerne erleben
werdet ihr manche dann besser und du
spürst du dich auch ein schlag durch
dein rücken wort scheiße gebaut hast du
auf deinen puls steckt noch immer hasen
und adrenalin fließt noch immer durch
seine blutbahn
genau in diesem moment erklärst du diese
doktor reale erfahrung für eine fantasie
deines verstandes und machst du mit dem
satz du nur ein tag und bedeutung zum
einen wird das natürlich die frage auf
woher wissen wir dass die realität nicht
auch noch ein weiterer traum ist aus dem
wir jeden augenblick aufmachen könnten
aber keine angst darum geht es in diesem
video nicht und zum anderen zeigt dieses
gedankenspiel dass unsere träume
entweder eine gleichwertige realität
oder zumindest eine sehr realistische
simulation unserer realität sein können
und genau deshalb ist dieses thema
luzide träumen auch so spannend weil es
uns möglich gibt jede nacht ein ganzes
leben zu leben
aber woher wissen wir jetzt eigentlich
das überhaupt funktioniert und die uns
nicht einfach alle anlügen schon in der
antike wurde das klarträumen zum
beispiel von aristo aber zb von
aristoteles erwähnt aber erst 1975 kam
der beweis
während der proband nachgewiesenen
geschlafen hat er in seinem traum mit
einem augen bewegungsmuster welches
vorher abgemacht wurde erfolgreich nach
außen kommuniziert womit sich vorstellt
dass viele träumen wissenschaftlich
nachweisen konnten und so funktioniert
das ganze
beide videos haben in etwa den gleichen
ansatz wobei das erste noch darauf
eingeht dass es wichtig ist eine gesunde
schlafhygiene zu haben die maßnahmen
dafür sind im prinzip die gleichen wie
die die ich auch schon in meinem video
einschlafen in einer minute erwähnt hat
und wen halten eine dunkles umfeld ein
ruhiges umfeld ohne lärm einen
geregelten schlafrhythmus kein zucker
oder social media kurz bevor man ins
bett geht und meditation den ansatz bade
videos kann man auf folgendes
runterbrechen erster sich sogenannte
recs angewöhnen zweitens 56 minuten
schlafen sich dann drittens becken
lassen und 15 minuten wach bleiben sich
danach wieder hinlegen und weiter zu
schlafen und auf jeden fall immer alle
träume sofort in ein traum tagebuch
festzuhalten realitätscheck skin meiner
meinung nach ziemlich krass nach dem
film inception und wir sind echt cool
das sind aktionen wie einem klar machen
sollen ob man gerade wach ist oder ob
man gerade träumt eine beliebte variante
ist es zum beispiel sich die nase
zuzuhalten und versuchen durch zu atmen
in echten schafft man das natürlich
nicht und einen wird schneller die luft
ausgehen im traum wird einem das aber
gelingen und dadurch merkt man im traum
dass man gerade gar nicht wach ist
sondern dass man träumt in dem man sich
diese realitätscheck zur gewohnheit
macht macht man diese dann auch
automatisch im traum und wird sich dann
das bewusst hey ich träume gerade
nachdem man sich dann hinlegt und für
sechs stunden schläft befindet man sich
kurz vor der rem schlafphase wir
durchgehend im schlaf mehrere
schlafphasen und die rem phase ist dabei
die die am besten geeignete für das
luzide träumen insbesonders die vierte
denn die ist nämlich länger als
diejenigen davor idealerweise klinge ich
unser wetter also kurz vor der vierten
rem schlafphase damit wir uns noch
einige zeit mit dem träumen oder unserem
traum tagebuch beschäftigen können wenn
wir uns jetzt wieder hinlegen ist das ja
wahrscheinlich dass wir direkt von einem
bewussten zustand in die rem schlafphase
gehen und dadurch etwas an unserem
bewusstsein mit den traum nehmen jetzt
ist die wahrscheinlichkeit für einen
luziden traum am größten egal ob wir
jetzt einen luziden traum hatten oder
nicht sollten wir jetzt als allererstes
nachdem wir aufgewacht sind unsere
träume so detailliert wie möglich
festhalten um unseren traum gedächtnis
zu schulen
natürlich bringen ist ja nichts und
einem traum der bank auszurauben wenn du
dich dann nicht daran erinnern kannst du
jetzt reich bist heute ist der erste tag
und ich fange damit an den
realitätscheck
in meinen alltag einzubauen ich habe
hier für ein kleines schnürchen und mein
handgelenk gebunden und immer wenn mir
das im alltag auffällt dann denke ich
quasi daran okay jetzt mache ich mir
realitätscheck
das damit einfach zu einer gewohnheit zu
machen es ist der 22 damit bleibt die
küche an der stelle auch geschlossen
genauso wie social media wird auch
geschlossen
ich mache einfach mal im flugmodus rein
damit damit ich einfach alle möglichen
ablenkungen ausschalten kann
jetzt lese ich noch ein bisschen um
runterzukommen vielleicht freue mich
heute nacht hier von den kollegen
es ist jetzt genau 23 uhr mein wecker
klingelt genau sechs stunden und hier
ist mein wunderschönes sind ins
notizbuch mit denen ich meine träume
festhalten werde
ich bin jetzt laufen gute nacht ich
hatte mir schon zu erwarten waren auch
keinen traum ich werde jetzt noch zehn
minuten bleiben um den gedanken des
luziden träumens weiter meinen verstand
einzubrennen ich finde das hat er toll
war es nachts noch mal aufzustehen und
seine gedanken darunter zu schreiben und
dann nämlich zu versuchen seine treue zu
kontrollieren ich weiß nicht ist dann
irgendwann richtig cooles feeling kann
sich das beschreiben ganz kurze
realitätscheck nicht erst ein paar
stunden schlafen und wer nicht an schlaf
immer mit dem gedanken denken ich werde
mutig träumen und mich daran erinnern
okay ich habe heute ein bisschen länger
geschlafen für uns normale stieg um 36
auf
jetzt ist es das mit dem einschlafen
dann aufwachen und dann wieder
einschlafen weil mir so gut funktioniert
mit dem träumen dass ich es einfach
begreiflich gemacht habe und auch diese
und dadurch aus dieser nacht vier träume
heraus gemolken hab dich alle hier
schöne notiert habe um meinen traum
gedächtnis schön schön zu trainieren
ganz wichtig reality check das heißt ich
bin nach die technik die ich vergangene
nacht genutzt habe heißt übrigens way
back to bed was auf deutsch soviel heißt
wie aufwachen und zurück ins bett das
ist eine sehr sehr gute anfänger technik
aber um noch schneller luzie zu träumen
werde ich diese technik mit einer
anderen kombiniert und zwar weil das
bedeutet weg in die oslo streamen und
auf deutsch so viel wie vom wachzustand
aus eingeleiteter klartraum bei dieser
technik versucht man grob gesagt seinem
verstand vor zu kaufen dass sein körper
bereits schläft und damit mehr oder
weniger bei vollem bewusstsein ins land
der träume mir abzurutschen und dabei
ein stück vom bewusstsein mit in die
träume zu nehmen wie ihr euch jetzt
vielleicht denken könnte das eine sehr
sehr fortgeschrittene technik aber in
meiner meditations- erfahrung mit der
erfahrung die ich in meinem letzten
video gemacht habe bei vollem
bewusstsein mitverfolgen kann wie ich
langsam die kontrolle über meinen körper
verliert bis ich letztendlich schlaf
eigentlich schon dass das ein versuch
wert sein könnte
dies ist mittlerweile wieder abends und
herren kommt zu erkennen ich hab es kann
auch gearbeitet und das jetzt schon ein
uhr nachts soviel zum thema schlaf
rhythmus
jetzt hast du noch ein bisschen was
lesen und danach schlafen gehen
ich halte mein körper jetzt komplett
still und ignoriere jedes kleine jucken
und bedürfnis mich zu wälzen mehr oder
weniger versuche ich mich in den schlaf
zu meditieren und hatte ganz kurz das
gefühl mein verstand zu lassen um ihnen
von einem anderen ort zu beobachten ganz
ohne eigene gedanken bis ich dann aber
kurz davor wieder in meinen verstand
zurück plus pin und nach wenigen minuten
eingeschlafen bin jetzt klingt jetzt
vielleicht komisch ja aber es hat sich
tatsächlich so angefühlt ich habe heute
einfach sechs träume in dieses trauma
tagebuch geschrieben was echt krass ist
weil eigentlich habe ich halt höchstens
einen traum die realitätscheck sven auch
langsam zur gewohnheit also den tag mit
dem band hier kann ich nur wärmstens
empfehlen
in einem der videos die ich mit diesem
experiment überprüfen möchte war die
rede von sogenannten banner
und das sind töne die die kommunikation
zwischen den gehirnhälften anregen
sollte und als ich das zum ersten mal
gehört habe dachte ich das wäre
kompletter aber mittlerweile bin ich mir
gar nicht mehr so sicher und es gibt
auch echt ein geiles experiment aber
dazu gibt es vielleicht sogar mal ein
extra video auf jeden fall werde ich das
heute mal mit einbauen und gucken ob das
hilft da das system haben wir wichtige
prüfung dann werde ich ihn ausnahmsweise
sind nicht um fünf uhr morgens in meinen
weg wollte deswegen werde ich eine
flasche wasser aus denken und hoffen
dass mich der drang aufs klo gehen zu
müssen einfach weg
okay ist jetzt und gewinntreiber morgen
7 auf den weg gebracht worden
der treffer dem was alles super
funktioniert ich habe das ganze bett
hier voll gepisst ich setze meine
kopfhörer auf und macht ansonsten wieder
alles genau wie gestern und hört dabei
eben die bei neuen beats die binaries
scheint irgendwie zu funktionieren aber
nicht ganz so wie gewünscht ich habe das
gefühl dass sie mein bewusstsein leicht
steigern aber irgendwie zu stark als
dass ich dann überhaupt noch einschlafen
könnte also ziehe ich meine kopfhörer
vorerst wieder aus und schlafen diese
nacht werde ich noch einige male
aufwachen und habe ungelogen acht
verschiedene träume die ich immer alle
meinen traum tagebuch notiere und je
mehr ich schreibe desto mehr details
fallen wieder zum jeweiligen traum ein
das ist zwar gut für das was wir
vorhaben aber irgendwann hat sie aber
wirklich keine lust mehr und wollte aber
noch schlafen es sind jetzt ein paar
tage vergangen und ich habe auf jeden
fall mein traum gedächtnis erheblich
steigern können
ich kann mich als jede nacht an fünf bis
acht räume erinnern was du nicht einfach
nur ab normal ist und ich ja noch immer
mehr musste kennen die sich wiederholen
und dinge die eben irgendein element in
dem anderen traum schon vorgekommen sind
und irgendwie durchziehen durch meine
träume
mir ist aufgefallen auf welche art und
weise sich elemente aus der realität in
meinem traum widerspiegeln und das ganze
hat mich auf die ein oder andere
thematik aufmerksam gemacht die ich zwar
im unterbewusstsein hab aber der ich
wahrscheinlich nicht die nötige
aufmerksamkeit widmen das einschlafen
übrigens auch immer mehr spaß gemacht
weil ich immer besser gelernt hat
bewusst war den schlaf abzutreten
aber wie ich am anfang schon befürchtet
hat ist das mit dem dutzend rollen nicht
ganz so flott gegangen wie die videos
die wir überprüfen glaubte also ich bin
mir sicher dass es die anderen andere
personen gibt bei der das auch sehr
schnell klappen kann aber ich bin mir
fast sicher dass es bei 99 prozent aller
menschen mehrere tage oder sogar monate
dauert bis sie ihren ersten platz und
raum hann
ich werde auf jeden fall weiter machen
und euch auf dem laufenden halten und
euch dann in ein paar tagen oder wochen
hoffentlich von meinen wegen abenteuern
dass das nutzen träumens berichten
können und wenn ihr mich jetzt auf
dieser reise begleiten möchtet dann
könnt ihr mich natürlich gern abonnieren
und dann sehen wir zunächst mal wieder
ciao
[Musik]
[Applaus]